good morning meleave nation my name is
Lily and my one word is extraordinary I
believe that every single human being is
capable of extraordinary things when
they embrace you truly are so to help
you on your journey today's message is
pushed through over to you Eric Thomas
if there's anything in life that you
don't currently have right now it's
because of who you are and how you think
come on right now you saying ET man you
talking to me man I'm going through some
type of pain I'm ready to quit and give
up let me see I ain't I'm ready to quit
and give up me see ya something in life
I'm ready to quit on give up on come on
raise your hand I'm ready to quit on I'm
ready to give up on it
come on raise it up alright what I need
you to do is I need you to find a reason
to keep going and if you can find a
reason to keep going I know you're
strong enough to do it because you'll
MIT then every human has what it takes
to get past whatever they going through
if they decide to push through it push
through it tragedy and trials coming to
everybody only the strong survive my
wife I watched my wife when she got
diagnosed I watched my wife have
terrible days and she didn't probably
miss two days of work the whole time she
had MS I watched her go to work and I'm
like boo why in the world would you get
up and go to work you don't even need
the money how would you do it is cold
his ten degrees in Michigan and your MS
flare-up when it's cold what are you
doing she said I can't see my daughter I
can't have my door to see me weak
is my daughter gonna be married one day
and my daughter gonna face tragedy one
day and I have to show her how to do it
so I get up and get dressed and I'm
gonna work every day so my baby girl can
know how to get through trials cuz one
day she ain't gonna be under our roof
and she gonna have to do it alone and I
don't want to talk I want to model what
it looks like my daughter got on the
prayer line to the prayer meeting up
today told her testimony lying you feel
like going to school I feel like walking
a mile to go to class and I thought
about it my mom got a chronic illness
and my mom and her forties can get up
with a chronic illness and go to work
while surely I can get up at 18 years
old and go to class it worked it worked
it worked
listen to me very closely y'all running
from obstacles when in fact it's the
obstacle that's gonna take you to the
next level like y'all running from pain
y'all running from challenges you
telling me how difficult your life is do
you understand it is the difficulty
that's gonna prepare you and take you to
that next level why do you keep crying
mommy God why don't I get you man while
I get cancer why did my mama died
why did I get fired do you understand
listen you got through that you got put
through that because what that does that
tension produces greatness not running
from it it run through it y'all y'all
gotta hear me the reason why you do what
you do is more critical than what you go
home and if why you do what you do is
weak I need you to go back and start all
over again because if your reasoning is
weak you're not gonna get it done why
because light is going to beat you
upside your head and I'm gonna tell you
this I don't care who you are and what
profession you in before you blow up
light will strip you to the pole but if
you wait you will be broke and I'm not
here because I'm the best I'm here
because they tried to break me and they
could if you want to be successful have
a huge goal wanna make a mess
impact in this world you will be
required to push through however that
looks like for you whether if it's
pushing through pain fear of failure
fear rejection whatever it is you have
to keep going too many people give up
too easily they have this big mission
these beautiful ideas but at the first
sight of hardship you give up and if you
look at anyone who we have covered on
this channel the person that you look up
to you
ninety-nine percent of the time they
will tell you that they have faced
massive adversities during their journey
but they kept persevering and pushing
through because if they hadn't they
wouldn't be successful you probably
wouldn't even know them because they
wouldn't be who they are today I think
about my own life and I think about how
lucky I was to be born for to be an
immigrant in this country to be the
poorest kid in my school did not have
the things that I wanted when I was a
child and I'm telling you all of these
things you're probably wondering oh
that's crazy that doesn't seem that
lucky that seems really unfortunate and
the reason why I think I'm lucky is
because I know how it's like to be on
the other side I know what the
alternative is I know how it's like to
be made fun of because I was born when I
was a kid which is what made me develop
my grit and hustle to keep working when
I was 13 years old
I got a job at a restaurant serving
breakfast which required me to wake up
at 5 a.m. in the morning let me tell you
as a 13 year old maybe a 13 year old
watching or you have a 13 year old or
you have been 13 you know that no 13
year old wants to wake up a 5 a.m. on
the weekends to go serve breakfast you
know I wanted to do things what other 13
kids do at 13
kids feel like they they want to go to
the mall they want to hang out their
friends but I didn't do any of that and
it was painful it was so hard for me and
it was also embarrassing because I
didn't want to tell my friends so all of
that was just a terrible experience but
what kept me going and pushing through
was knowing what the alternative was
knowing that if I didn't do this I would
continue to be poor even at that age I
knew that I wanted something much bigger
than what I was at that time I wanted to
become the best version of myself I
wanted to afford luxurious things you
know to me at the time was a nice pair
of shoes because all my shoes were and
me downs and secondhand I bought at
garage sales I wanted a nice pair of
minty shoes that's what I wanted so
that's what kept me going at at age of
13 and now it's 20 years later and I'm
so glad I experienced that 30 even
though I hated every moment of it I was
so glad that I did that because it did I
develop the skill to have the
perseverance that I required today as an
entrepreneur as an entrepreneur you are
going to be challenged in ways that
you've never been challenged before if
you're working for someone else because
everything is on you you guys see me
standing on TEDx speaking in front of
all of these people and yes that is a
beautiful celebration and I loved every
single moment of it but what you don't
see are all the rejection emails that I
got from the
neck's places telling me that I didn't
get in telling me that my ideas not good
enough not maybe I should try next year
and I could have easily given up and say
you know what maybe then think about for
me you know the rejection there's only
so much rejection someone can take
before they snap and give up but I kept
going because I always know what the
alternative is the alternative is that I
do not meet my mission my mission is to
build a world where we can all move
towards our truest potential and if I'm
not doing it how can I possibly inspire
others to do the same what a waste of
life and that pain is so painful that it
surpasses any immediate pain of
rejection or failure or anything that
happened and it helps me keep going for
you
maybe you're going through some tough
time right now and I understand life
gets hard life is not all about roses
and cupcakes and unicorns and fancy
stuff life gets real and it gets hard
maybe I'm going through a failure right
now maybe you're going through your 30th
failure and you just want to give up
it's too hard and I'm gonna tell you
please do not give up you have to keep
going and I know you know there are
certain things that you feel like I'm
just not passionate about I'm gonna give
up that's fine if I all means give up on
those and move on to the next as quickly
as possible but if there's something in
your heart in your gut and you really
want it so passionately like you feel
like you can't breathe without it do not
give up on it at all especially when
things get really hard because what is
the alternative for you remind yourself
of the alternative if your dream is to
be a fitness trainer and inspire
millions of people to become fit and you
want to end obesity and if you don't
push through and go to the gym at 5 a.m.
in the morning that you're required to
do so because you're too tired because
you've been working all day what is the
alternative for you the alternative for
you is that people are going to continue
to die from obesity and you could have
helped them I think you didn't and you
are not able to meet your dream and
being the fitness instructor inspiring
millions of people
now how does that feel pretty painful
right and that pain is going to push you
through and help you wake up early in
the morning go to the go to the gym
wherever you need and that's just an
example there's so many other things
that people want and I know you're drawn
to this channel because you have a big
mission because you want to inspire
people because you want to look up to
people who inspire others you have a
mission inside of you and if you give up
the alternative really really is being
bullheaded sucks
and finally the push of the day is what
is that one thing that you do to help
yourself
push through please leave in the
comments below and hopefully by leaving
in all the comments you're gonna help
someone else and motivate them to push
through as well and of course I'm going
to be sure to join them on the
discussion as well have a special shout
out for skip and Pritchard thank you so
much for picking up a copy of Evansville
getting your one word and tweeting about
it your support means a lot to us and I
really hope you've enjoyed the read and
thank you so much for watching I believe
in you and I hope you continue to
believe in yourself and whatever your
one word is and we'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot of an
espresso
between those things you also went to
Broadway with Julie Roberts with Paul
Rudd three days of rain that must have
been pretty special yeah it was a
do-or-die moment for me actually I think
Kitchen Confidential had gotten canceled
you know I and and I remember thinking
if this doesn't work maybe I'm not right
for this business I thought I thought
that their moments in life anything like
you know it kind of does matter if this
fails or you fail in it and and it was
hard it was one of them it was the
hardest thing I've ever been through by
far and I remember thinking if I can get
through this I don't it may be as hard
but there's it's impossible for it to be
harder and it's true and it's and I've
had a lot of hard time since and more
jobs you know when you're like wow the
pressure is so intense but it always I
have such a foundation for three days
gonna say that eight shows a week right
not even that actually was the rehearsal
process not to do once we got on stage
it flew and that thank God and I thought
oh this feels right but it was a you
know and I was hard on myself you know
but it was just man it was tough I think
it being present and enjoying what
happened is is is important I guess what
I'm saying is like like yesterday I ran
I did an hour and it was you know 92 or
93 degrees outside
it was hot right but I didn't say like
hey do I is this gonna be enjoyable or
not I said look this is what I do and
come hell or high water I'm gonna do it
you know and and and and it was enjoy I
got it wasn't enjoyable at first but I
but I pushed through that it's like on
the other side of that resistance is
often that thing and so I think that's
the problem with people who are like you
know I'll just sort of go with the flow
I'll take it as it happens that can work
but you know it's often on the other
side of what you're afraid of that you
experience really great things and you
have to have the power to push through
there's different types of people in
this world and one thing that we'll all
want to deal with is like difficulties
in our tasks trying to become successful
as good as things get you would have the
same amount of bad that's going to try
to impede your progress whether it be
people whether it be the IRS whether it
be whatever something will
rear its ugly head and try this block
you now a lot of people can't handle
that
when you have a vision and something or
someone throws a curveball
it hurts this thing's right it's like
your baby and now I can't put my baby
out there like I want to do it so it
really throws people off that you think
negative maybe the president want to
stop they might want to just go back to
the 9 to 5 that's fine it's not for
everybody to push through but for those
who can please do like he said the
difference between those who really
succeed don't are the ones who when
they're faced with whatever these
difficulties are did I I'm gonna keep
pushing through because there's some
corny and cliche but it's always
sunshine after the rain you're gonna be
saying rain don't last that long you got
to know that be aware that that's when
you can take what you do with everything
in life but in business you cannot stop
because they said I want to write at the
time because it's gonna happen
I'll deal with it I'm sure are doing it
again sometime
raise your standard Apple at the pool
its core value is that we believe that
people with passion and not one drop of
most self-worth depends on your
acceptance of me I don't ever give up
I'd have to be dead or absolutely
incapacitate hey believe nation if you
want to see my all-time favorite top 10
most a success I have a very special
secret video for you these are the
individual clips that I have personally
learned the most from and applied to my
life and my business check the link in
description for details